it was 26 years ago that Luke Perry
helped make 902 window the most famous
ZIP code and the world well now he's
coming back to TV and as new show as a
famous address as well talk to me about
Riverdale Riverdale town without a zip
code no zip code but Luke is taking up
residence and a new series based on the
Archie comic books he's playing Fred
Andrews Artie's dad I got a call from
your coach today how are you guys gonna
be putting a modern twist on such a
classic iconic comic book
they got 21st century problems they got
21st century relationships it's very
modern football takes you to college
college takes you to business school
business school takes me back here to
work for you in Riverdale though based
on the comic this is no Saturday morning
cartoon dangerous cinema he had no idea
Luke's character owns a construction
company weird it's interesting because
when he first talked to et over 25 years
ago he was fresh off a road crew a year
ago I was shoveling asphalt in a year
from now I could be doing it again I
think it keeps a good perspective on
things as long as you remember that Luke
went from that one of the world's
biggest heart throbs the only thing I'm
finding difficult is a little less
privacy you know people know who you are
you just don't know who they are you
don't see them on TV now 50 Luke is back
in Riverdale and after having two kids
he says he's completely at home in the
role you know I think on some ways this
this character is the closest one to me
that I've ever played because he's a guy
that loves his kid and that's really all
he's about
kind of what I'm about
[Music]
Oh